singer/songwriter Jake Owen had finished
performing at the route 91 Harvest
Festival when the shooting broke out we
spoke to him earlier this morning by
telephone you were there
how are you processing this it's very
very upsetting I'm just absolutely blown
away I mean I'm what I'm sitting here
inside a bus a hundred feet from the
stage that I was standing on when this
started happening I'm watching the news
now saying that there's more than 50
people deceased and 200 injured and it's
I ran out I was in the we were in the
middle of it I mean when the shots are
being fired and you could hear a
ricocheting off the top of the roof of
the stage we started just running in any
direction we could because you didn't
know where it was something you know
someone was on the ground he didn't know
where I was coming from and at one point
I was kind of sitting on the ground
behind a car with about 20 other people
crouched down on the car and just the
fear and everyone's eyes but yet the
feeling of everyone looking for someone
to make sure they were okay was it was
just an it was I just never experienced
anything like this what did you think
was happening Jake when you first heard
the shots number one did you know they
were shots well ironically enough when I
walked up on the stage earlier or not
they were pretty the security was pretty
tight because Jason uses pyrotechnics
and I think the fire marshal didn't want
a lot of people backstage or side-stage
due to their fire it was it would come
off those pyrotechnics so when I was
standing up there talking to my buddy
Luke combs who's also an artist on the
show all of a sudden you heard him start
you heard these pops start and I thought
it was perhaps the pyrotechnics and I
realized once it started like a
literally sounded like a full-on
automatic suzy or machine gun that was
coming that's when you knew that it was
not the pyrotechnics then it was someone
shooting an automatic rifle jason
released a tweet this morning expressing
his condolences have you talked to him
since since since this incident
I have we've talked briefly through text
message along with you other my friends
they were here they're artists as well
we all are just kind of in shock you
know we all were checking on each other
thinking everyone making sure everyone
was okay because literally we we
were running in chaos people had no idea
where they were going how to get I was
separated my own crew of that friend of
mine is here with me now she got
separated from her husband I couldn't
get a hold of each other so we were all
just been you know worrying what was
going on
yeah how long did the gunfire last how
long did it appear to last that's what's
really in that's what's crazy about this
story is that I believe that the
gunshots no joke lasted for anywhere
between eight ten minutes because it was
almost like you could hear it first and
others are saying they're showing
obviously we're shooting for Angela it
makes more sense haki the first few
shots came off individually there's
almost like as if he's broke the window
or something of the room we're shooting
from that point just unloaded an
automatic rifle out there's a sea of
people but I mean I ran offstage when he
was firing shots ended up getting in the
street behind the car or sitting there
for a couple minutes while he was still
firing shots and by the time I got back
over to a crew bus in the middle of a
parking lot a few hundred yards away we
all laid down inside the tour bus and
you could still hear them firing shots
on and it went on for a good like I said
six to ten minute what is your message
to your fans who who were there who
across the country who may be tuning in
and watching you right now relive the
horror of what happened just hours ago
what is your message to them you know I
would I at the end as a like I said a
minute ago I'm just gotta sing songs you
know I write songs my best ability about
the things I know and lies that I think
it's important for us in the simple way
we can say it to those out there that
come to these shows every weekend and
every week they bring their families to
not be scared of this you know we're
still gonna get out there and do this
and this is so unfortunate that things
like this have to happen to have to
happen in order for us you really see
that this kind of thing is real